[Musique]
bienvenue en quête la mafia c'est connu
cherche à étendre ses tentacules partout
à montréal
elle est parvenue à jouer un rôle
important dans développement de la ville
nous vous racontons ce soir l'histoire
d'un homme d'affaires proche de la mafia
à l'origine de divers projets
immobiliers d'importance notamment la
transformation en condos de luxe à coups
de dizaines de millions de dollars d'un
bâtiment patrimonial
un projet qui pourrait en partie
expliquer le meurtre survenue il ya
trois ans tenez crésus aux juniors
enquête sur un promoteur qui vit
aujourd'hui cacher craignant un attentat
du clan rizzuto le mille de la commune
d'ans lieu port de montréal une des
adresses prestigieuses en ville avec ses
200 condos luxueux des gens d'affaires
très riches habitent des vedettes russie
même julian roberts ya séjourné lors
d'un tournage à montréal des joueurs des
canadiens comme andrei kostitsyn et
changé depuis 2002 commune un endroit de
rêve mais qui a aussi été l'adresse de
batié le mille de la commune est
comparable un peu à eux banker le mille
de la commune a été aménagé au début des
années 2000 par un promoteur dont le nom
est aujourd'hui associé à la mafia touly
majhi
combien au juste sont réservés
80 % et s'est même pas non si tu as fait
une ouverture déjà six semaines ici dans
le vieux port dans sept jours lors l'été
la fondation parité tony magi malgré ses
liens connus aujourd'hui avec le crime
organisé a eu pendant longtemps ses
entrées auprès de policiers montréalais
ont représenté monsieur maji son équipe
avec un projet bien utile qui venu dans
votre bureau est venu dans mon bureau
comment un entrepreneur qui fraye avec
la mafia et son chef vito rizzuto
faut-il réussir à s'infiltrer dans les
plus hauts lieux du pouvoir montréalais
[Musique]
cet édifice fait partie du paysage
montréalais depuis près d'un siècle
inauguré en 1922 c'était à l'origine un
entrepôt frigorifique
mais en 1978 le bâtiment a été
désaffectée vingt ans plus tard on lui
cherche une nouvelle vocation
initialement le projet retenu allier à
la fois habitations commerces et espaces
publics
mais comme par magie il se
métamorphosera un immeuble à condos de
luxe
le grand public n'y aura plus accès
contrairement aux objectifs
d'aménagement de la ville
[Musique]
autre revirement l'entrepreneur
sélectionné initialement disparaît de la
scène et c'est tout lima ji qui fait son
apparition avec son entreprise
or go team qui va acheter l'ancien
entrepôt pour le revendre en condos est
une sorte de pastiche et cachette
vous avez des personnes qui sont à un
gain qui gagnent entre 45 en 2000 par
année
si vous avez des passants qui gagne 100
mille deux cent mille sont pour tout le
monde secundo lançons pour tout le monde
magie rayonne lors du lancement son
projet de prestige en 1999 suis content
puis mauriac contente avec le projet qui
se finit mais déjà à l'époque le nom de
maji éveillé des soupçons
jean fortier alors président du comité
exécutif de la ville de montréal demande
un avis aux recteurs général de la ville
qui coulombe
monsieur coulombe avait été directeur la
sûreté du québec dans quand on imagine à
vérifier et puis je vérifier gibbons
alors repris quelques jours une mère
venue pays maudit j'avais raison mais
chez vous
jean faure qui connaissait magic sommes
petits constructeurs sans manières dans
son quartier de notre dame de grâce il
avait acheté le monastère des
dominicains en promettant d'en faire une
résidence pour personnes âgées
puis nouveau coup de théâtre magie vu
plus tôt et bâtir des condos et sans
attendre l'autorisation de la ville des
arbres centenaires sont coupés sur le
site de l'ancien monastère au grand dam
des citoyens
[Applaudissements]
quelques semaines plus tard tony magi
obtient quand même un changement de
zonage jean fortier se souvient de
l'avoir alors confronté
j'ai contacté dont on imagine alors j'ai
dit qu'est ce que tu as fais là qu'est
ce que vous avez fait la cck manie ce
que j'avais pu d'expression avec
d'inapproprié mais elle lui s'est forgée
il me dit écoute ta pas la fermer
d'autres sites se mêle de ça tu vas voir
ta prochaine élection sera aux élus
jean fortier dit avoir informé le maire
bourquais l'époque des menaces de tony
magi
aujourd'hui l'ancien maire préfère
rester loin des caméras avant cette
rencontre
nous l'avions rejoint au téléphone il a
dit n'avoir qu'un vague souvenir de
cette époque jean fortes y affirme
aujourd'hui que le projet du maire de la
commune était majeur pour le maire
bourque et son entourage
tout ce que je sais c'est que y avait
des gens qui auraient voulu mettre
l'accélérateur sont sur le projet pour
faire démarrer dès le début les
problèmes se sont accumulés pour le mil
de la commune faute de fonds le chantier
fermé les fournisseurs de maji sont aux
abois en 2003 sa compagnie airblue team
s'est placée sous la protection de la
loi des créanciers l'homme d'affaires
terry pomeranz apparaît comme le sauveur
du projet mais des conversations
téléphoniques captées par l'opération
colisée sur l'histoire mystérieuse de
vol
révèle que lui et maji entretenait à
l'époque un contact avec le parrain de
la mafia dans la nuit du 28 au 29 mai
2003 par man s'appelle monsieur régis
tôt pour lui dit qu'il a été victime
d'un vol d'automobile et il demande à ce
résultat s'il peut l'aider à retrouver
le véhicule en question et ce qui
intéresse beaucoup plus monsieur baumann
c'est moins le véhicule que la mallette
qui se trouve à l'intérieur du véhicule
quand on trouve le véhicule on se rend
compte que la mallette n'est pas
l'intérieur et le même jour recommence
dans le sens où il ya des appels qui
sont faits monsieur rizutto quitter les
fans surtout monsieur magic communique
avec monsieur lesotho pour l'us de la
manette n'est pas l'intérieur et dans
les heures qui suivent on récupère la
mallette qui est livré dans un
restaurant à montréal pour le compte de
monsieur pommade au téléphone teri pa
man s'est montré plus loquace lorsque
nous l'avons interrogé sur ses liens
avec vito rizutto et ton imaginant la
preuve que des conversations avec vito
et jetant sur une voiture qui avait été
volée et votre vie ok bon souvenir de
cela et c'est ce que m'ont dit mais je
lis lui dans la preuve que les villes
c'est vous c'est en fait besoin l'avant
ok jusqu'à ce que les questions de
george bush et ce qu'on dit c'est que
vous étiez le forum des riches des
communes
je voulais le nom de maji revient
ensuite dans diverses enquêtes
policières
en 2005 il est enlevé à la salle avant
de réussir à échapper à ses ravisseurs
en 2008 il est la cible d'une tentative
de meurtre il a été littéralement
mitraillées
alors qu'il était au volant de sa range
dans l'ouest de montréal après avoir
sombré dans le coma madghis est sorti
miraculeusement de l'attentât la
tentative d'assassinât serait telle
relié aux dates de maji à l'égard de
l'entourage de btu résultats notamment
dans le projet du mail de la commune nos
sources policières pense que oui le fils
de vito rizzuto est vu à de nombreuses
reprises en compagnie de tony magi
toujours selon nos sources le parrain de
la mafia avait chargé son fils nick
junior de multiplier les pressions
surtout les magic pour qu'il rembourse
ses dettes
[Musique]
en décembre 2009 n'est que junior est
assassiné en sortant d'un immeuble à
condos construits juste en face des
bureaux de ftm la compagnie de maji tony
magi a joué un rôle dans cet assassinat
certaines sources policières le pense la
députée maria mourani et criminologue
spécialisé dans les gangs de rue et la
mafia
selon les informations que j'ai ce
contrat là auraient été exécutés par
joseph ducarme à la demande
tony magi et donc c'est bien sur des
allégations
les raisons qu'on m'a mené alors et
qu'on m'amène toujours c'est d'une part
le fait que vito rizzuto a été déporté
qui ait eu disons ce cette espèce
d'instabilité à savoir qui va reprendre
le contrôle
on dit il a dû choisir son camp les
représailles n'ont pas tardé le 18 march
2010 moins de trois mois après le
meurtre de nick rizzuto junior
ducarme joseph échappe à un attentat
mais pas son garde du corps
quelques mois plus tard c'est la femme
de tony magic est visé dans son quartier
elle s'en sort indemne
selon nos sources policières les dettes
de maji envers l'entourage de vito
rizzuto dans le projet du maire de la
commune serait en partie à l'origine de
toute cette violence on sait aussi que
la famille de victor et jude law a
acheté cinq condos de terry pomme orange
pour la somme de 1 $ pour par la suite
les revendre en fait selon nos
recherches
une vingtaine de personnes liées de près
ou de loin au crime organisé ont été
propriétaires ou ont déjà séjourné pour
mille de la commune des mafieux comme
vittorio mirare qui la colette de
raynald desjardins arrêté pour le
meurtre de salvatore montagna de
dangereux membres de gangs de rue comme
ducarme joseph et victor sévère pussy
des avengers dont robert baillargeon et
charles bourassa qui a été arrêté
normand casper ouimet qui a été vue à
plusieurs reprises tous des criminels
qui pouvaient s'y rencontrer à l'abri
des regards indiscrets
l'ex inspecteur de la sûreté du québec
cen'est tremblay a travaillé sur des
enquêtes majeures à la sûreté du québec
dont chaque et diligence la façon dont
2002 la commune est placé c'est très
difficile pour une équipe de filature de
s'avancer de surveiller quelqu'un un
véhicule ou une personne à partir des
alentours de ce bâtiment lorsque pour le
crime organisé c'est très très
intéressant donc si c'est sécuritaire de
l'extérieur donc eu à l'intérieur ont le
loisir de se promener de se changer d
information l'ex-dirigeant policiers
soupçonnent aussi que des criminels
ayant blanchi de l'argent on parlait
souvent de location d'appartement à 4000
dollars par mois dont 4 on parle de
l'achat on parle d'achats d'un condo qui
était d'1 million à plus d'un million
donc pour eux évidemment c'est très
facile dit blanchir de l'argent à cet
endroit
officiellement tony magi n'a plus aucun
lien avec le milieu comme une métairie
pomeranz l'homme à la mallette y possède
encore quatre condos
malgré ses mésaventures maji demeurer au
fil des ans un joueur important dans
l'immobilier de l'ouest de montréal
il a été le promoteur du projet de
plusieurs millions de dollars à la chine
et à la salle l'a eu un accès direct au
maire de l'endroit
même après l'attentât de 2008 300
familles
alors elle a terminé le projet est
certaine notoriété publique
effectivement il avait été victime d'un
attentat mais je ne vais pas axer mois
tous les renseignements criminels sur
les personnes qui viennent à nos bureaux
c'est pas écrit dans leur forme à ce que
je sache je me suis madge était un homme
libre et en liberté était pas sous les
verrous et c'est un homme d'affaires
alors moi y'a perds mon bureau pim dit
je suis en train d'acheter un terrain
privé je veux construire chez vous alors
clients après avoir travaillé avec le
service demandé à me rencontrer
alors je les ai rencontrés comme un
homme d'affaires même michael applebaum
a eu des entretiens avec lui alors qu'il
était maire d'arrondissement
il a dit qu'il ne connaissait pas si
liens avec la mafia
dans toutes ces années c était un homme
d'affaires qui faisait des souvent les
mauvaises projet mais c'était quelqu'un
qui était reconnue dans le quartier
comme une homme d'affaires la même
financé un dj sort quand il y avait à
peu près 1500 2000 enfants qui est ce on
avait une folle le le marque de son
commerce non sur le dos de tout les
joueurs de soccer la marque de commerce
en question et qu de m
en partie propriété de tony magi le
maire a de bons estime qu'on ne peut pas
comparer ces rencontres avec magic avec
celle de claude dauphin et manon barbe
la différence c'est que j'ai pas moi je
n'ai pas rencontré un monsieur à
monsieur magie depuis que j'ai pris
connaissance qui avait ptt et des liens
avec la mafia a appris que l'été tante
etc d'un maître g pas rencontré monsieur
magie d'où l'image y aussi parvenus à
tisser des liens de proximité avec des
fonctionnaires de l'arrondissement de
monsieur à pau bombe
subsol oui bonjour cervelle de radio
canada un seul à jean yves buisson un
cadre des permis et inspections et de
l'urbanisme l'a rencontré à plusieurs
reprises nous subissons été impliqué
dans le projet de construction de condos
par la compagnie de tony magi ou 57 57
ap la chine d'un dj
un projet au centre d'une vive
controverse ces dernières semaines
monsieur buisson a même déjà dîné dans
ce restaurant avec tous les magic est
nul autre que le fils du parrain nick
rizzuto junior vous l'avais jamais
rencontré d'autres fois il savait que
c'est kim savistes qui n'est que le
juste génial pour les mains non mais je
connais déjà vingt ans par history
j'étais tellement live avec cgt
actuellement le jeu avec ses thèmes et
ses 20 ans s'était y était lui aux
lauréats tab
ils étaient à la table parce qu'il
voulait parler des hopis poser des bleus
parler de quoi
au niveau justement les règlements de
bain est pendant dix ans nous subissons
était locataire d'un appartement à la
salle appartenant à construction ftm la
compagnie de tony magi quelques jours
avant sa retraite en 2008 il a acheté
l'appartement transformées en condos au
prix de 210 mille dollars sans aucune
liste de fonds juby sion affirme qu'il
avait une entente privée avec naji
prévoyant que les deux tiers de son
loyer 600 dollars par mois et est déduit
pour l'achat de son condo une entente
rétroactive signé le jour de l'achat
vous n'êtes que vous avez pu davantage
du chemin dit quand vous avez acheté sur
chute j'en ai buisson nous a déclaré
avoir perdu 15 mille dollars à la vente
du condo les documents notariés disent
pourtant le contraire il aurait fait un
profit de 40 mille dollars en quinze
mois
le contrôleur de la ville de montréal à
la ronde nous a confirmé la tenue d'une
enquête sur jean yves buisson et sa
relation avec tony magi on retrouve le
nom de maji dans plusieurs enquêtes en
2009 il est mêlé à une histoire
d'agression violente dans ses bureaux
en 2010 il est arrêté pour possession
d'armes
il obtiendra dans ce dossier une
absolution nous avons tenté de
rencontrer tony magi pour obtenir sa
version des faits en nous rendant chez
lui mais un garde du corps nous en a
empêchés depuis le meurtre de nick
rizzuto junior plus personne ne voit
tony magi dont le nom figurerait au haut
de la liste noire de vito rizzuto
entre temps plusieurs des condos du mais
de la commune liée à des membres du
crime organisé ont été vendus y at il
encore des bandits qui y vivent
difficile de le dire mais pas plus tard
qu'en novembre dernier la police yonnais
une autre perquisition